the more people that we have solving the
critical problems that everyone in the
universe faces the better we are as a
society a diverse perspective is uh one
of the richest perspectives that you can
have i'm natalie walton
and i am the ceo and co-founder of
expectful
[Music]
midway through my pregnancy i found out
that i was high risk and the situation
created a ton of stress in my life one
where i was going to the doctor five
times a week and quite frankly i didn't
know if i would make it to term i needed
to find a way to cope with the stress
and one of the skills that i learned was
actually
that i found through expectful and that
was cultivating a meditation and
mindfulness practice
the meditation and mindfulness practice
was so critical to me because it helped
me
control what i the only thing i could
control and that was my mind in the way
that i responded to the situation
and quite frankly that is a skill that
i've taken as a new parent
during sleepless nights and taking it
through the pandemic and i've most
certainly taken that with me um as an
entrepreneur after i returned to
maternity for maternity leave
i
was just in a different state of mind
and as a new parent i was just thinking
about what is what is my purpose in life
how am i going to really have an impact
and i had a conversation with the
founder of the company and he asked me
to come on a ceo so
what started as a an avid user then
turned into an advisor and then leading
the company now
expectable did start as a meditation and
sleep app but as a pandemic parent
i
my world was blown away when i realized
how difficult it is to be
a pregnant and new mother in today's day
and age and i saw a much bigger
opportunity for respectful beyond
meditation and sleep i saw the need for
a wellness platform for
fertility pregnancy and parenthood and
so when i came on to expectful that was
my first thing that i wanted to do was i
wanted to pivot i wanted to grow our
business
as a black female entrepreneur
i
am often
underestimated
and one of the things i love most is
proving people wrong
so i've done that time and time again
throughout my career but particularly in
this job for example um coming in 90
days into the job i closed our seed
round i raised 4.2 million dollars in
less than 90 days
and for me that was quite an
accomplishment and particularly as a
black female
as black females receive so little of
venture funding and so
um being underestimated i think is a
core strength for for many but it is
particularly one for myself
you can never underestimate hard work
when you're fundraising
it is a job where i would take calls at
6am with folks in europe and i was
closing the day at 9pm with people in
hong kong and so it's a combination of
hustle
storytelling and just grit and that is
what helped me persevere
[Music]